hello everyone
so i am retrieved and i was recently a
part of this program
that was held by pine biotech named
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
this whole was a program which taught
about certain parasites
viruses bacteria like corona
ebola rhino tuberculosis and malaria
it also explained us in depth about
diseases like
aids malaria flu tuberculosis
vineyard virus etc one of the main
implications in this program was to
bring in the application of
bioinformatics
in treatment research sequencing and
understanding
the infectious disease and host pathogen
interactions
this whole program was a session
included into 10 parts the 10 sessions
twice a week and the mentors for the
program were
elia brocky who is the co-founder and
ceo
dr muhammad mazindar who is a phd in
computational biology and dr harpreet
kaur who is a phd in bioinformatics she
was as our bioinformatics trainer
dr mohit musumdar was partnerships and
project mentor
and ilya brodsky was the one who led
this all sessions
so talking about the purpose of this
program the purpose of this program was
generally to get into depth and
understand about certain parasitic
genomics squirrel genomics
and how they have evolved over the past
few years actions and their courses
second one of the most important purpose
of the program was to investigate our
immune responses
how we react to certain pathogens third
was finding the biomarkers
like when any type of infectious disease
is caused
biomarkers indicate a very important
tool for design vaccine
vaccine design and drug design fourth
was to study the microbiome study
that is the structure function of host
and pathogen
and third was the coast course of
infection which included host pathogen
interactions
how the host inverted our immune system
the artificial ways the tags the
phenomena and further wrong
so the main program of it was the
infectious disease program so we were
basically done the difference between
infectious and non-infectious diseases
which as we know infectious disease is
spread through context that is from
person to person and it is contagious
and it is spreaded by pathogenic
microorganisms like virus bacteria
parasites fungi
non-infectious diseases are non-contact
use and deadline spread by
contact further they are spreaded by
environmental
factors nutritional deficiencies genetic
inheritance mutations lifestyles etc
there is a particular way by how
pathogens spread
it might be by replication in their own
breed or colonization in particular
environment it can be due to cell death
and there can be a chance of bacteria or
virus entering into our immune system
because certain types of immune cells
are dead
it can also be due to organ function
damage or the release of certain harmful
toxins which can prevent the
use of certain microbes into our body
this is the whole picture i have
picturized this is
used to understand first how the
pathogens
interact and replicate what techniques
are used for the sequencing
the genome sequence and the application
of the genome sequencing now we know
that
ngs is a system that transforms the
data sequences the genome sequences into
data file formats like fasta fast q
bam metron etc so further these genomes
of
of say of any pathogen is further used
for getting a pure insight into
virulence capacity of that particular
parasite
it is also used for studying the protein
expression and using this protein
expression vaccine design and drug
design is done
they're also used to study the
population structure and evolutionary
history of that particular parasite
which gives a comparative analysis of
genome sequencing
and strains of same species if they're
involved or not
are more violent or not it is also used
for studying specific sequences of
strain detection
it is also used for diagnostic purposes
of how they have used by
pcr address or dna microarrays and
proteins are immunoprecipitated using
protein expression which are further
used for cellological tests of extreme
development or development of 3d
structures of protein which is further
used for drug design
moving on and further section 3 and 4
and 5 we were given a hands-on tutorial
about how to make a demo pipeline of
msa that is multiple sequence alignment
over here we were also taught about how
to use certain platforms like ncb
wireless
viral genome platform where we can
download the genomic sequences and
alignment reads of certain viruses on
certain but almost
all viruses according to the year of
violence
further we were also taught the some of
the methods and concepts of replication
also we were taught methods of rna
sequence alignments which
known which were known as targeting
amplification
which is the first one and involves a
gene or a conjunction of specific genome
which is very highly variable second was
total dnr
rna that is by microarrays which helps
to know certain non-genes
third was by amplicon and environmental
conservation
which used to which is used this method
which is used to conserve
hyper variable regions so this was the
thing third fourth fifth with an
hands-on
session on making a demo pipeline so
this is a picture which shows the
mutation variant
parallel analysis of mutation variance
so this is a
demo pipeline we rain and for the more
we uh we downloaded the genomic
sequences of certain viruses like ebola
plasmodium plasmodium falciparum etc
and then we further made the mutation
pipeline to find out what type of
mutations are present in which gene the
lipid content etc
there were many more pipelines we had
done this is just an example
in session 7 8 and 9 and 10 we were
taught about the
host pathogen interactions in host
pathogen interaction we understood the
mechanism by which the
microbes interact and invade our immune
system
we will also learn we also learned about
rna sequence
overview which included three main steps
that is pre-processing mapping
and quantification of expression levels
using this quantification of expression
levels we
understood about certain type of protein
function that is how
amino acid sequences what is the 3d
structure
what is the high throughput data now
amino acid sequencing and further
branches we talked about the sequence
simulated the similarity and the
features of the particular amino acid
sequence
the 3d structure told more about global
and local
types of proteins and what proteins are
used what are the iso forms etc
in high throughput data we learned about
protein interaction and gene expression
on the same platform
using differential expression and
network analysis we were further able to
study the gene expression
in depth of any particular type of
organism say it a human
or any model organisms so this was
taught and after this
10 sessions we were given a two week
stands for which we have to
think about the project we would like to
work on bioinformatics
of infectious diseases the project title
and hypothesis could be any
and our mentors told that they would be
helping with
taking this project further so overall
it was a very good session
and had a very deep insight on how
infectious disease
play an important role together in
hand-in-hand with bioinformatics
thank you